i'm actually like a pretty big moon
knight fan i don't know if anyone would
know that about me or if i've ever
really spoken about it obviously i found
out about moon knight when i started
reading comics uh when i was i think i
was about 13.
um
and moon knight was generally a
character who was just in the other
stories i was reading i wasn't buying
moon knight comics
um just a side character but then i got
a little bit more interested in moon
knight specifically and bought
standalone moon night stuff
when i started playing more and more
marvel vs capcom which moon knight is a
character in um
so
this trailer which just dropped
yesterday marvel studios
moon knight official trailer 2022
featuring oscar isaac and ethan hawk i'm
watching this on ign um the fact that it
also has oscar isaac who is obviously an
incredible actor is super exciting but
uh there's a lot of really cool stories
that they could pick from here um i'm
really interested to see where it goes
so this is my first time watching the
trailer of course
um i don't know what to expect
i'm looking forward to it let's do it
hello and welcome to staying awake i
have a sleeping disorder
i can't tell the difference
between my waking life
and dreams
i mean this is already beautifully shot
surprising nobody
i think i'm losing it
who is speaking we'll catch you you're
bloody useless
stevie steven
[Music]
that's been oscar isaac
the whole time that's been him
hope you find it
thanks
i assumed that i was hearing somebody
else speak
oh my god
i'm so distracted by that that i feel
like i'm not paying attention
what the hell okay
oh much wow
oh my god you're alive what's wrong with
you mark
why did you call me mark
ooh this would be very difficult
a voice
in your head
shut up
this chaos
[Music]
i think he gets so creative with this
the chaos
i
at first was thinking they weren't gonna
give him his full costume i was like
maybe they won't
that actually looks pretty awesome
kind of surprising though i wonder like
what the origin story is of him actually
getting
the costume is kind of surprising to me
um loved it i love that trailer um
outside of being completely shook by his
guy
um
very cool i really really hope that it
doesn't you know give world ending
stakes that's the thing that i really
don't like if they do with a character a
new character from the jump in the mcu
is if the stakes are a little bit too
high just keep it contained i feel like
even outside of like the avengers the
group movies i prefer things stay a bit
more contained um and i hope they do
that with this uh it definitely has the
vibe of my current favorite mcu movie uh
which is
uh winter soldier um i really hope that
they kind of
stick to
the the mystery what's going on what's
real and what isn't kind of thing i just
love that that sort of vibe huge fan so
yeah i want to see that suit again
though
i mean i think that looks a little bit
silly
to be honest
but i'm interested how you go from this
to this
wow really cool trailer i liked it a lot
uh i loved reading comments on these so
let's have a look shall we
see how other people feel about it
love it looks and feels most like an
actual series movie rather than mcu
tie-in not to sing the other marvel
shows but it's oh wait hang on sorry is
this a show
it is it's a series i assumed it was a
movie shows how up-to-date i am
and clearly i don't follow news too much
anymore
interesting that makes me less
interested
but it does look self-contained um not
just in other marvel shows but it's
about time we finally got one that isn't
about pre-existing lauren characters
with the mcu i strongly agree with that
let it stand alone
i'm glad to see
finally see marvel make a series on
moonlight he's incredibly underrated i
agree i really like midnight his hype
looks like a suspense horror
psychological type movie looks great
looking forward to seeing this um again
it is a series
yeah but i strongly agree some of my
favorite stuff about wanda vision which
i did really enjoy um i've actually not
seen loki i know that i should
um was not knowing what's real knowing
what wasn't like the kind of
psychological elements of that um the
exploration of like
grief and other people's fear um getting
into
you know just like the human emotions of
it less than a big superhero villain
because we got a lot of big superhero
villains they managed to get the dark
and gritty tone right boy to love the
show i agree punisher
hopefully this series will inspire
marvel disney to start releasing more
disney plus series with a mature dark
tone strongly agree with that yeah i
would say that um
like book of boba fett to me i'm really
not enjoying and i would say um
part of that could be because i feel
like it could be
a lot more mature in tone than it is but
i'm sure a lot of people disagree with
me on that
daredevil type show yeah
i agree good use the kid cuddy song it's
a great song
day and night
seems like their response is super
positive
yeah very cool
and i mean he's an amazing actor i'm so
blown away by that voice wow um yeah i'm
excited about it i'm definitely gonna
watch it this has sold me you know like
i i won't necessarily even think that i
am interested in watching tv series
because it's so time consuming um
but i'm watching this i'm in let's go
let me know what you guys think